I don't want to do that Christmas album
they want you in the studio tomorrow
tomorrow they want you to record with
one of the other artists in their stable
Oh Derek Copeland from the boy band I'm
Derek
Tess big fan of your work what's your
favorite song and we need a clean and
polish sound for the record no I think
it needs to have a more organic live
vibe to it needs to be as clean as
possible to stick out above the fray
these lyrics are from the Stone Age you
see if you could do better
yeah I do guys what sort of songs you
working on Alexander you guys in the
same studio me what's it like working
together great yeah yeah every day has
been a real treat
I cannot referee every little small
decision between YouTube if you don't
get on the same page
we're not gonna have an album to even
talk about do you think we could have at
least one original track on the album
what are you thinking a love song oh
really this is the one you like you like
her don't be absurd to all you do I kind
of like her I'm gonna try that original
track tonight it's not ready gonna need
to release that baby to the world's
people can hear it
[Music]
you've helped me rediscover my love for
music and I'm grateful for the time that
we spend together do you think you're in
a place where you could do that put
someone before myself oh my man take
something
[Music]
Carrie Underwood's manager just called
they want you on the tour starting in
January you kidding me it would be crazy
not to take that to her that is the
difference between you and me because if
I ever have to choose between family and
career
I choose family every time
I don't want to end things like this
thanks Mike
[Music]
you understand my life is complicated
not anymore
[Music]
you